[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
60 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
Thanks, Francesc.
How are you doing?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I'm pretty tired.
It's been a long day.
It is a Saturday.
And I have been working--
I've been having fun at
[INAUDIBLE] all day long--
but also very happy to be here
for a very awesome interview,
actually.
How about you?
Let's not be impolite.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm doing--
[CHUCKLING]
I'm good.
It's a Saturday.
But you know what?
With travel schedules
and work being how it is,
this is when we
found time to record.
Yeah, I'm also excited
about today's episode.
We're talking about FaaSs,
Functions as a Service.
I've never actually said
the word "FaaS" before.
I think that's fantastic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Is that
how you pronounce it?
MARK MANDEL: How else
would you pronounce it?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I don't know.
FaaS.
MARK MANDEL: FaaS.
Fuzz?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Like the
ice cream, Haagen-Dazs.
It's FaaS.
MARK MANDEL: You know what?
I could get behind FaaS.
I could do FaaS.
Actually, I like that a lot.
But yeah, we're talking with
Soam Vasani about Fission,
the Functions as a
Service thing that
works on top of Kubernetes.
So that's pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is pretty awesome
because basically,
the way it happened
is that we gave them a shout-out
doing our last episode.
It was one of the Cool
Things of the Week.
And we said, hey,
it'd be awesome
if you're listening to this.
Let us know.
And we'd like to interview you.
Well, that happened, basically.
MARK MANDEL: Pretty much.
We're like, hey, what are
you doing on Saturday?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah--
pretty awesome.
And after that
interview with Soam,
we are going to have our
Question of the Week, which
is about all the things
that I love networking.
So HTTPS and WebSockets
and load balancing--
how do you make
all of those things
work together nicely on
Google Cloud Platform.
MARK MANDEL: Before
we do that, though,
why don't we get stuck into
our Cool Things of the Week?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let's do that.
We have so many.
Where do we want to start?
I tell you what--
I will start with one
of my favorite things,
obviously, Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: One
of the favorite topics.
MARK MANDEL: One of
my favorite topics.
So there is an article that
came out on the Kubernetes blog
about running highly
available Kubernetes clusters.
So basically, the standard
Kubernetes system right now
runs on a single master.
That works reasonably well in
that if the master falls over
and-- it's fine.
It doesn't actually
destroy anything.
But if people have been looking
for multi-master setups,
especially high-availability
setups across multiple regions,
there's a great article
showing how that's currently
been supported on Google Compute
Engine in the Kubernetes 1.5
release, and shows you all the
commands you need to use to set
that up, which is pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
So what happens now if
you're saying that if--
now we have two masters
for higher availability?
What happens if you have
a master and it goes down?
Does that mean that the
whole cluster goes down?
MARK MANDEL: No, it doesn't,
which is pretty good.
So you should
monitor your masters.
That's important.
But if your master does
go down, all your pods
continue to keep running
like they would do normally.
So this is how you
can do upgrades.
And if something horrible
happens, then that's great.
Then that's not great.
That's-- something
horrible happens.
Then you're covered.
Your services aren't
going to go down.
And your systems aren't
But if your master goes
down, keep an eye on it
and then bring it
back up quickly.
But it's not going to mean
your services are going to die,
which is pretty cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Following on the
topic of Kubernetes,
there is another blog post--
it's a Medium post--
from Jacopo Daeli.
I'm going to assume
he's Italian.
And it's about
Kubernetes and how
to do continuous deployment
to Google Container
Engine with Travis CI.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It's pretty cool.
He steps you through
all the things.
I learned something new in this.
I was looking through it.
There's a kubectl
set image command
that lets you change images
on deployments and daemon
sets and stuff.
I've done that by editing
YAML files and then applying.
But it's kind of cool
that you can do it just
in a single command.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
That is cool.
I didn't know, either, that
you could do that, actually.
It's pretty fun.
Why don't we go to the third to
last question, the question--
no--
Cool Thing of the Week, which
is about SQL Server Enterprise.
I think that now we have
pre-configured images for them,
right?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
It looks like we have
pre-configured images
for Microsoft SQL
Server Enterprise
and Windows Server
Core on Compute Engine.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And I think that one of
the coolest parts of this
is there's also some
instructions to set them up
with high availability and
disaster recovery, which
means that basically
you're going
to be running every single
instance in a different zone.
So even if one whole
zone goes down,
you will still
have your database
running all the time,
which is very important--
and disaster recovery, which
means that you will not
lose a single piece of data,
which is something that we all
want to have.
MARK MANDEL: I think this
is also kind of cool.
It's mentioned here, as well,
that finally all of the Windows
Server images are now enabled
with Windows Remote Management
Support, which is pretty nice
if you need to manage fleets
of Windows machines.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
Cool.
I think it's time to go
talk to Soam with Fission.
What do you think?
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good to me.
Let's go do that.
So today's episode
is brought to you
by what happens when you reach
out via your podcast and say,
hey, it would be really
great if we interviewed
that person on the podcast, and
they listened to the podcast,
and then they come and they
are on the podcast, which
is really cool.
So I would like to
introduce Soam Vasani.
Soam, thank you so much
for joining us today.
How are you doing?
SOAM VASANI: Great.
How are you?
Thanks for having me.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Really, really good.
Before we get stuck into
talking about fission.io,
why don't you tell
us a little bit
about who you are, what you
do, the company you work for,
all that sort of good stuff?
SOAM VASANI: Yeah.
So I joined Platform9
about a year ago.
It's a company that
does SaaS-managed--
it started out as a
SaaS-managed system
for on-prem infrastructure.
So people would add
their hosts, and you
would get an online
control plane for them.
We started doing OpenStack
and then, about a year ago,
started working with
Kubernetes as well.
And I worked for
a while at VMware.
That's how I know some of the
people who started the company.
And I had worked on
various things at VMware--
infrastructure management
stuff, some storage systems,
and some other random
projects in between.
And so that's why I joined
here and was working
on this Kubernetes
management plane
and then maybe about
four to six months ago
started working on Fission.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And what is your
role on Fission?
SOAM VASANI: So I'm the
software engineer on it.
It's actually mainly just
one person right now.
So I guess I'm software engineer
and doing a little bit of--
I don't know--
marketing you can say,
but talking about it to
other people as well.
So yeah-- a little
bit of everything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm actually curious about--
you told the story a
little bit of how you got
started with Kubernetes.
But how did fission.io start?
When did someone be
like, oh, we should
have functions on Kubernetes?
Could you tell us a
little bit about that?
SOAM VASANI: Yeah.
Yeah.
So the actual thing
started in a hackathon.
We have these little
internal company hackathons
every few months.
And I'd been simultaneously
excited about AWS Lambda
and serverless
around the same time,
and also because we
were taking Kubernetes
to companies who hadn't really
worked with containers before
at all.
And so both Docker and
Kubernetes were new to them.
They knew that they were
excited about Kubernetes
and wanted to use it.
And we take it to
them and deploy it.
And then they would--
their next question
would be, how do I
do something useful with this?
And we didn't have any
helpful answer other than,
go read the manual, try out
some examples, and so on.
So we really wanted something
where we can give users
something where-- a simple,
a really simple app--
can be brought up
in the first day
that you have a
Kubernetes cluster.
And so this hackathon
provided a really--
a short way to make
some kind of prototype.
That's when we made this
Node.js thing, which basically
wrapped a Node.js function
at runtime into a container
and brought it up as a
service, and you could
start doing requests to it.
So it is early prototype
about six months ago.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So on the Fission website,
it says serverless functions
for Kubernetes.
SOAM VASANI: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: What
does that mean?
What does that actually
look like, say,
as a developer experience,
and also just conceptually?
SOAM VASANI: So even though
we say functions is actually
modules more properly,
so you write a--
so the programmer writes
a Node.js or Python
module with one function
as the entry point,
as the sole export
of that module.
And then Fission takes
that and turns it
into an HTTP service
that runs on Kubernetes.
And it also manages the
lifecycle of that service,
creating it, instantiating
it when there's a request,
killing it when it's
idle, scaling it,
potentially-- things like that.
So the programmer has
a simple interface.
They write a module and a
function which takes a context.
The context contains
the request, and so on.
And they just implement
the service there.
And then Fission is
responsible for taking it
from a source code file to a
running service on Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you mentioned one
thing, which I guess
is because of the way you
build your containers, which
is you said that you were
able to do Python and Node.js.
I am myself a little
bit of a gopher.
Is Go coming at some point
or is there any reasons why
Go is not supported?
And you say you're supporting
these languages that
are interpreted, which
I assume there is?
SOAM VASANI: Yeah.
Yeah.
So this is an exciting topic.
This is what we're
working on right now.
MARK MANDEL: Yay.
SOAM VASANI: So
today, our function--
it goes from a source
code file directly
into the execution environment.
And Fission framework
hits a dynamic loader
that's inside that container and
loads that function and routes
requests to it.
So now we want to enhance
this pipeline a bit
to add support for
compiled languages,
dependency resolution step--
so installing
dependencies, linking them
in whatever way that's
defined in the language.
So what we're doing
is taking a step back,
looking at how we define
these language environment,
and think, today we just have
an execution environment.
Now you also need a
build environment.
And the build environment is--
Fission will just
say, your source code
goes as some sort of artifact
into the build environment
and in a language specific where
the built environment turns
that source artifact
into a dynamically
loadable, runnable artifact.
So in the case of Go, you would
upload a set of source files
and maybe some spec
of dependencies.
And then the builder would
output either a binary
or maybe plugins using
Go's newish plugin support.
And then the
execution environment
would load that plugin.
And Fission would be responsible
for orchestrating this, running
the build when the user uploads
a function, managing compile
errors and that
iteration cycle, and then
transporting the binary, storing
it, caching it, and so on.
The infrastructure
for Go support
is being built right now.
And then on top of that, we'll
build the Go lang support.
MARK MANDEL: Do you have other
languages in the pipeline
as well?
SOAM VASANI: Yeah.
So we already have
Node.js, Python.
Somebody contributed
PHP and C# .NET.
The C# .NET support
is interesting
because it's a
compiled language.
But what it does is it
compiles it at runtime.
So that's an interesting
way to do it.
It's not ideal.
We want to change that.
But it is supported for now.
So yeah.
Those are the languages.
There's a contributor who's
working on Ruby right now.
Like I said, we're
working on the support
for compiled languages.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So you touched on it
a little bit before,
but I'd like to talk
about it specifically.
Why serverless?
Why is that a thing?
What does that mean to you?
And why was this
so important to you
when you came up
with this project?
SOAM VASANI: So the
term "serverless"
itself is a bit vague.
So I think the general
idea is that it's
to sort of ask, what's the
simplest interface you can have
to write applications that
still can be used in production,
that's still useful, usable to
create services in production?
And I think this
Functions as a Service
is one approach to that.
I'd say it's not
100% proven yet.
But we think it'll get there.
So I think Functions
as a Service
is sort of maybe a more
precise or a more specific
form of serverless.
But to answer your
question, why serverless?
I think it's-- there's a
pattern there of saying,
how simple can we make
this and still be useful?
I think there's different
approaches to that.
And Functions as a
Service is one approach
that I am excited about.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So the
question that I have now-- it's
the question that
pretty much started
this episode, which was not that
long ago, we had the monolith.
And we had one binary.
And for that binary,
we had a bunch of code.
That's it.
Now, next, we move
to microservices.
And all of a sudden, we have
a bunch of different binaries
or processes.
And at the same
time, we might have
a bunch of different repos.
And then now we're
moving to functions.
And I'm curious about how do you
manage the complexity of having
so many different
pieces of source code
that are somehow related
but possibly stored
in different places?
How do you manage them?
SOAM VASANI: So that's
a few questions there.
I think when you have a
large set of functions,
how do you put them together?
We decompose data application
into a bunch of little pieces.
Now how do we put the
pieces back together?
And compatibility is
one of the issues there.
So I think this is a bit of
an open area for Functions
as a Service.
I think it's a bit of a language
and framework design problem.
So we've got to
try a few things.
So I think one
thing that we need
is support for some
sort of composability.
So you need using code
to be able to compose
other functions together.
Today, most of the
FaaS implementations
don't do that very well.
You create an event
or HTTP request.
And you can call
other functions.
But there isn't a formal
way to call other functions
through the framework itself.
And so we need that.
So we need some sort
of composability.
And I think we need
some sort of grouping,
either modules, namespaces,
packages, something
like that that can
let you assemble
your functions together.
So you still have some notion
of separation between functions.
But a program, after
all, like you said,
is many functions and modules.
So you need some
constructs to group them.
And then that will also help
with the compatibility question
because then you can version
the repository as a whole.
So we don't have
any of this today.
But it's some ideas
on what to do.
For example, you
might have a Git repo
with a manifest at the top
level, something that looks
kind of like a
Kubernetes YAML file.
And so it would say, this
subdirectory or this set
of files over here is--
forms a function here.
It imports that
module over there.
And this other set of files
is this other function.
And the whole thing is
versioned as a whole.
And so you could
imagine deploying.
You could imagine pointing the
Fission tools at that manifest,
and the thing wraps it up
as some sort of package.
And Fission figures
out how to run that.
So that's very hand-wavy
and a little vague.
But we want to experiment
with something like that.
Like I said, it's
not a solved problem.
And we've got to try things
out and see how that goes.
Today, the main
utility tends to be,
maybe because of this
problem, in smaller use
cases, especially event handling
and webhooks, a small slack
bar, that sort of thing.
MARK MANDEL: That's
actually what
I was going to actually
segue into, which is great.
I was going to ask you,
then, given what you said,
what do you think the
major use cases for this?
I know personally, like when
I looked at this, the fact
that phishing can handle
not only HTTP events,
but also Kubernetes events--
to do the glue stuff
within Kubernetes.
Was that what you think
it would be used for,
or what are the use
cases you think are going
to be particularly useful here?
SOAM VASANI: So I
think initially,
it's very useful for small
REST APIs and maybe--
a webhook is basically
a one-endpoint REST API,
you could say--
and slack bars and
little automation,
like OK, let's pipe events from
Kubernetes or other sources
into that system and
use that to glue it
into other infrastructure.
I expect that to be
the main use case.
And I see the actual usage
also tends to be like that.
So we haven't [AUDIO OUT] some
CI systems or automated builds,
triggers, some functions.
And we track, test failures,
and so on using these things.
The idea of having a
bigger app implemented
this way-- it's definitely
something we'd like to reach.
But that's definitely a
more speculative use case.
We'll have to see how that goes.
I'm excited about that use case.
I think it would be really
nice to be able to specify,
mostly in a language-neutral
way, how a REST API should
be deployed and run on
Fission, and have Fission take
care of that after
deployment and scaling
and things like that.
But we're not quite there
yet for bigger programs.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I'm actually curious.
You mentioned a
couple of use cases,
like managing some
events and stuff.
Could you tell us a
little bit about what
are the use cases for, which
you think that Functions
as a Service is a much better
metaphor than, let's say,
Infrastructure as a Service
or Platform as a Service?
SOAM VASANI: Again, like
today, the event handling stuff
is the best use case for that.
If you just want to write,
say, some trigger for--
for example, we have--
we were just discussing
this within the company
a few days ago--
we have this source code
cross-referencing tool
that today polls our
Git repositories.
And so we figured
we could just--
we could change it to have
a small webhook that's
triggered every time you
do a commit to a repo.
And that webhooks would go and
poke this source code indexing
thing that would re-index
whatever changed,
or at least the
repo that changed.
And then you wouldn't
have to pull the Git repo.
So now if you
imagine implementing
this as either Infrastructure
as a Service or microservices,
you have to--
it's a little bit more involved.
You have to create
the service around it.
If you're running
it on the VM, you
have to worry about the
whole operating system.
If you're on Kubernetes, you're
definitely a bit better off.
But I think where this
Function as a Service helps
is that you don't
quite have to worry
as much about the capacity
of the cluster in terms
of the number of
services you deploy.
So in some sense,
creating a service
becomes cheaper, both in
terms of development cost
and runtime infrastructure cost.
So basically, our
cluster capacity
becomes more a function of usage
than of the size and number
of services that
you've deployed.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So I'm curious about
something else as well.
Fission is built on
top of Kubernetes.
SOAM VASANI: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: Why did you choose
Kubernetes as the platform?
What was the
reasoning behind that?
SOAM VASANI: So a few
different things-- one
is that Kubernetes provides
so much of the stuff
that we'd have to build if
we didn't use Kubernetes
or something like it that, from
a purely implementation point
of view, it just
makes a lot of sense.
We don't even know about nodes.
Kubernetes completely takes
care of the cluster management
itself.
We don't have any
real scheduler.
We might have some
scheduling decisions to make.
But Kubernetes takes care of the
bulk of scheduling decisions.
We don't have to do any
complex storage integration.
We would just be able
to use Kubernetes
volumes, its networking,
secret management.
So in terms of
implementations, Kubernetes
takes us way ahead than we
would if we started without it.
So that's one story from an
implementation point of view.
From a user's point
of view, we think--
so I don't think Functions as
a Service will replace the idea
of microservices or just
putting services in containers
and running long-lived services
because there's plenty of use
cases where you want
to do that for--
like let's say
you're running Redis.
It doesn't make any
sense to kill Redis
when it isn't doing
requests because it
would lose all its memory.
So obviously, that has to
be a long-lived process.
So if you're using
that, then the question
is, as part of your bigger--
as part of your
overall solution,
how do you mix together
Functions as a Service
and regular services?
And I think Kubernetes
is a good place
to bring those all
together because you
can get service discovery,
maybe, between these things.
You can just easily have
them on the same cluster.
You could in the future
maybe do some smart things
with scheduling.
And what else?
So it's basically
[? interrupt ?] with services,
the implementation
advantages, the reuse
of Kubernetes concepts, like
secrets, volumes, and so on.
And I think there's also
an operational benefit.
You don't want to run
two clusters for--
one for services and
one for functions.
It's better to have fewer
systems that you manage.
So if you're already managing
a Kubernetes cluster,
managing its nodes,
managing etcd and its state,
then you might as
well spend that--
you might as well reuse that
effort to run functions on.
And so if you have something
like a log monitoring framework
and monitoring stuff
like Prometheus
you could just reuse
that with Fission.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm curious about--
you were talking about
all the cool things
about building on Kubernetes.
So I'm going to go the
other way and ask you
what was the biggest challenge
about building something
like Fission on
top of Kubernetes?
SOAM VASANI: For the most part,
once I got past the learning
curve, figured out how to use
the client, a lot of things
were super doable.
The API is very complete.
It's very comprehensive.
I could talk about a few
challenges that we just
haven't solved yet.
So one thing is volumes.
I spoke about how it's
awesome that we can reuse
Kubernetes' storage management.
But the way volumes
work conflicts
with the way we
dynamically load functions.
So let me roll back a bit.
When we started this, we
tried to just take a function,
wrap it in an
image, and just do--
just create a
Kubernetes deployment
on a service using
that image on demand.
But that takes a
few seconds at best.
Even if you pre-pull the
image and cache it everywhere,
that still takes a few seconds.
And when people do
Functions as a Service,
they expect a faster
cold start on the order
of 100 milliseconds,
even less sometimes.
But that's the goal
we've aimed for so far.
So to do that, we needed to
have already running ports.
And so when you create a--
when you add support for
Node.js or Python to Fission,
then Fission creates a pool
of these pods that are already
running before you even have
any requests for a function.
And then when the
request comes in,
the function's loaded
in there and run.
And that has a smaller
overhead because the overhead
of starting a pod
was already taken
before the request came in.
So now what to do with
things like volumes,
because it's not possible
today, neither in Docker not
Kubernetes, to mount a volume
on an existing running pod,
as far as I know.
I have tried to figure this out.
But it looks like that
is not possible today.
So if your function
wants to use a volume,
then you have to lose the
cold start optimization, which
means you have to start the pod
when the function request comes
in or we have to figure out
something separate from the way
volumes work today, like maybe
have a separate pod that then
the function can connect
to to get at its storage--
something like that.
But basically, mounting
storage is a challenge
we haven't figured out yet.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Maybe
one of our listeners
may be able to help with that.
Who knows?
SOAM VASANI: Yeah.
I hope so.
Yeah.
Today, the answer
is that we would
have maybe some sort of
separate mode where you just--
where you lose the
cold start optimization
if you really want volumes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I have one more
very short question.
What language did you
used to implement this?
SOAM VASANI: It's all in Go.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
SOAM VASANI: Yeah.
It's actually my first
non-trivial Go project--
so very much learning as I go.
I had a few initial
puzzling moments with Go.
But now I like it a lot.
And I'm very excited
to be using it.
I sort of started with
it because Kubernetes
was written in it.
And also, it seemed
to be getting popular.
I didn't have a strong reason
to adopt one over the--
Go over something like
Node.js, which is what
I was familiar with before.
But I've really enjoyed
making this in Go.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: We're definitely
running out of time.
So very quickly, what is
the plans for the future?
What's in the
roadmap for Fission?
SOAM VASANI: So I
think we addressed
a few major pieces of effort.
The current major effort
is improving that function
pipeline, supporting
compiled languages.
After that, we want to get
at improving the developer
workflow a bit, dealing with--
having better support
for versioning.
We have very, very basic
versioning support today.
There is support, but
it's a bit manual--
doesn't [? interrupt ?] with
Git as nicely as we like.
And then there's more language
support, better integration
with Kubernetes'
volume, secrets,
config maps, and of course,
integrations with more event
sources, integration with
some sort of message queue.
There's NATS-- maybe Kafka
or something like that.
And finally, we have a lot
of performance tuning to do.
We don't do auto-scaling today.
But we need to do
that both up and down,
things like that, and
also latency improvements,
both in cold start
and in the fast path.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Soam, thank you so much
for joining us today.
I think we're going to have to
cut it there just because we're
running out of time.
But we really appreciate you--
SOAM VASANI: Thank you so much.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, definitely--
for coming down and talking
to us, especially on a Saturday.
We really love that.
It was really interesting to
talk about Fission with you.
SOAM VASANI: This is awesome.
Thank you so much for having me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
Great.
That was a great
interview with Soam.
Thank you so much
for taking the times,
as you said, especially on
a Saturday, to talk to us
and tell us a little bit about
why and how you implemented
a FaaS on top of Kubernetes.
MARK MANDEL: Super, super cool.
As I've said before, I'm
quite interested in how
you can use this
to basically build
quick little bits of
glue inside Kubernetes
and connecting that
to other things.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm very excited especially
about the Go support
coming soon, maybe
using Go plugins, which
is something that's
coming with Go [INAUDIBLE]
that we release
actually probably
right now as we're talking.
The Go [INAUDIBLE] will
be released on Wednesday.
So that should be cool.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, why don't we move into
our Question of the Week?
I know you had a
particularly interesting one
about WebSockets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So as I was saying at the
beginning of the episode,
it's about-- it's something that
I really don't know that much,
but it is important.
Many people know that, if
you have a global service,
you need to do load balancing.
And many people
know that, if you
want to have a very
responsive web page,
WebSockets can help you.
And we all know that it
is important to secure
all of the things with HTTPS.
But when you try to use
WebSockets over HTTPS load
balancer, if you read the
documentation, it says, no,
you cannot do that.
What's the deal with this?
How do you do it?
MARK MANDEL: What
is going on here?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
What is going on?
MARK MANDEL: What is going on?
So it's a good question,
and one I've definitely
run into before.
So yes, if you're doing HTTP
or HTTPS load balancing,
we have a global
Layer 7 load balancer
that helps support that.
That load balancer doesn't
support WebSockets.
So it's like, what do I do?
So WebSockets
themselves on HTTP--
WebSockets run over
a TCP protocol.
They're negotiated
and kind of managed
by HTTP, by the browser and
the servers, to, like, how--
where do I connect to and where?
But they are a TCP connection.
So we need a TCP load balancer--
is essentially what we need.
And Google Cloud Platform
has a TCP load balancer,
which is great.
But what we also want
is we want SSL support
because much like HTTP
and HTTPS-- security good.
So what we can do, then, is
we set up a TCP load balancer
and network load balancer.
But we set it up with
what's called an SSL proxy.
And once we do that,
things pretty much
work as you would expect.
So when you go to set up
your network load balancer--
and actually, the
console server--
console.cloud.google.com
has a really nice interface
for this now where, if you go
in there and you're like, hey,
I need load balancing
for my network,
it'll give you the options.
You can then select
TCP load balancing.
And then when you
go in to configure,
it'll actually ask you,
connection termination--
do you want an SSL proxy or
do you just want straight TCP?
So you are then able to
select proxy and then
go configure from there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: So you're
totally able to do WebSockets.
You just need a slightly
different type of load balancer
to run them over.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Little
side question about it--
you mentioned that--
it's like when it's an SSL load
balancer, you can choose TCP.
Is there anything
else you can choose?
Can you choose UDP?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
You can totally do that as well.
It actually has that
as three options
when you go in,
like HTTP or HTTPS
load balancing,
TCP load balancing,
as well as UDP load
balancing as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, I think that's
bringing things to a close.
Francesc, you up to anything
particularly interesting?
Is there "Just for Func"?
I hear there might
be a "Just for Func."
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
I did release a new "Just
for Func" episode finally.
And it was very successful.
It is implementing
"Flappy Bird."
I call it "Flappy Gopher"
because it's written in Go.
And in two days, it
got almost 3,000 views.
So I guess the people like it.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah-- lots of fun.
And also, I've been working
with the Go plugins, actually,
that come with Go [INAUDIBLE].
And I wrote a demo about it.
And we'll have a link to that.
So if you want to do
hard code swapping
in Go, which is
something-- it was not
doable until this version,
check out the repo.
It's-- everything
on GitHub already.
So it's easy.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And what about you?
MARK MANDEL: What about me?
When this comes
out, there will be
a blog post live on my website.
I actually just wrote one for--
if you're a game
developer and you
want to come to Cloud next,
which is literally the week
after GDC, and you want to come
there and you're like, hey,
maybe there's some
game development
sessions that are
relevant for me,
there are actually quite a few.
So if you do anything with
backender multiplayer games,
or anything like that,
we even have stuff
for on location-based games
and all sorts of interesting
stuff--
may be well worth a read.
But otherwise, just getting
ready for GDC and Next.
Those are my big things.
GDC's going to be huge.
Next is going to be huge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Yeah.
For me, it's just going to be
coming back to San Francisco
soon and then [INAUDIBLE]
and then Cloud Next,
which is going to be pretty
intense, as you're saying--
but ready for that.
I'm actually very excited--
a lot of podcast
things going on for
that-- so very excited
about all the planning
and hopefully seeing many
of our listeners out there.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
Absolutely.
We will be set up at Cloud Next.
So please come up, say hello.
We may have some swag.
We may.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes.
I'm sure we'll
have some t-shirts.
MARK MANDEL: T-shirts, stickers.
We'll find some stuff.
We'll definitely
find some stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I think that today
it's a very good day
to remind our listeners how
they can get in touch with us
if they want to ask questions
or propose some topics,
or just say that they
love us, whatever
they feel like they say.
So why don't we do that?
Let's do it the other
way around today.
So I'm going to say the
medium, and you say the handle.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So let's
start with the easy ones.
We have a web page.
MARK MANDEL: Gcppodcast.com
or cloud.google.com/podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
We do have an email, too.
MARK MANDEL: Hello@gcppodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: If I remember
correctly, we have a Twitter.
MARK MANDEL: @GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We have Google+.
MARK MANDEL: +GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We are on Reddit.
MARK MANDEL: At /R/GCPPodcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: On Myspace--
no, we're not.
MARK MANDEL: We
are not on Myspace.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Which one--
oh, I'm forgetting Slack.
We are also on Slack.
We have a channel.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, #podcast
on the Slack Google Cloud
community.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
I think that's it.
MARK MANDEL: That is it.
I just want make
a quick shout-out.
If you do something that's
cool, like if you're like, hey,
I wrote a blog post or I have an
open source project or anything
like that, and you think it'd
be interesting for the podcast,
please send it through.
We're always looking for more
Cool Things of the Week done
by the community.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And also, something
that we proposed last year--
if you have questions
and you'd like
to send them to us as an
audio file, that'd be awesome.
So we could use your own
voice on our podcast.
That'd be awesome.
You'd become basically
famous instantaneously.
So it is an opportunity to take.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Great.
Well, Francesc, thank you
for joining me yet again
for another week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you for
waking up early on a Saturday.
MARK MANDEL: No problem.
And talk to you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
talk to you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]